i know we had this conversation but it
seems like
we both love doing our podcasts we both
like oh man i
kind of this is this is great i'm
fulfilled i have great fans and
listeners and i enjoy it i feel like i'm
making a difference i'm
i'm improving as a human being uh you
know i guess when does it become enough
because i see you do all these things
and you're
two kids we gotta what's up lincoln's
what seven
yeah five and seven five in dakota yeah
so i'm like holy man
you got this family you got it's just
you do so much
and sometimes i wonder why do these
people why does my friend
do as much as that why doesn't he just
show the out
why what is it psychologically you just
need to do more and more and more and
more
well i think there's there's a there's
many many reasons why one
one is um i'll start with the grossest
i'm a i have a
huge fear of financial insecurity
despite the fact
that i have no financial insecurity it
doesn't matter because fears aren't
generally reality based so
you know i'm from a very modest
background and my mom built this
business and
and money was a big priority in our
lives and and sacrifice for money was
what you did and so you know i have a
hard time if someone calls me and says
hey
you want to make x amount of money in a
week by filming 10 episodes of a game
show in a week
and i'm going to say no i think i'm good
without that money i can't imagine
saying that but
so there's that uh
two uh all those things
i actually enjoy doing right so it's not
like
none of them am i on my way there going
like i gotta do this
i don't have that feeling so there's
there's no downside the only the only
real stress is like again bless this
messes so many hours
i'd start going like i don't like
that i'm just either
waking my girls up and driving them to
school or putting them down
i don't like having to decide if i only
get to do one of those things
i don't love that i bring my kids to set
it's so boring i feel terrible
for him then i regret it oh why'd i
bring him here well i wanted to see him
oh there's nothing for them to do
you know that all happens but uh
there's a uh strike while the iron's hot
mentality
uh i just wanna stockpile money so i'm
not ever
look you know what i don't wanna do i
don't wanna be 80
uh playing a guy who poops his pants in
a scene that no one knows their name
because i need the money
uh i could be and i don't want to be in
that seat check that part i probably
will take this
i'll take that part yeah i'll take that
fart i'll take that shark
you